-And, finally, it is Wednesday,
and we all know what that means.
It's time for some
"Monday Motivations."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You're so popular,
when someone says November,
everyone else is like, "Oh, you
mean McKenzie's birthday month?"
[ Applause ]
After they welcome you
onto the flight,
the pilots go into the cockpit,
shut the door behind them,
and go, "Oh, my God,
he's here.
Be cool, be cool."
[ Laughter and applause ]
No matter what you went as
for Halloween,
people assumed
you were the sexy version.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Go ahead, say you're vegan.
People care.
[ Laughter and applause ]
When you read on the subway,
everyone's like,
"Oh, he's the full package."
[ Laughter and applause ]
If you'd been on stage
that night, John Wilkes Booth
would've been like,
"Forget Abe Lincoln.
I want to see
the rest of this play."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, this year,
your uncle's gonna show up
to Thanksgiving like,
"I've given it some thought,
and I realize, you're right."
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you go.
Thank you.
We have a great show, everyone.
Octavia Spencer is here tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Octavia!
Matthias Schweighofer
is on the show!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we've got great stand-up
from Kurt Braunohler.
Stick around.
We're playing "Catchphrase"
when we come back.